[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAVE STANKE: Hello, everyone.
We're going to go
ahead and get started.
Thank you for coming today.
My name is Dave Stanke,
and I'm a developer
advocate here at Google Cloud.
And we're here today to
talk about build and test.
When we say built, we
really mean build and test.
Because if we didn't
test our code,
or if we didn't have tests,
we can't say, really,
with confidence that
we built it correctly.
So when we talk about
this today and in general,
we use the word build as a
shortcut for build and test.
And sometimes we use the
word test as a shortcut
because it includes
the build process.
And I'm going to use
that shortcut today
as we go through this.
Importantly, I want you
to know that everything
that we talk about
here applies equally
to building and testing.
So what does this
build and test thing?
Well, that's the process
where we take our source code,
we run it through
a series of steps.
Might do some static
analyses or linting,
then we're going to do
transpilation or compilation,
packaging, and turn it
into something that people
can run and use as software.
And the process by doing that
is called a build process.
And if you write software, or
if people in your organization
write software, chances are
you have a build process.
And chances are you
use a build system
to perform that build process.
And this can vary
depend on the language
that you're working in.
You probably are
using it every day,
or people in your
organization are,
but you may not think
about it very much.
But you're probably using it.
So do we have any Java
developers in the house?
All right, you may be using
them like Maven or Gradle.
Any C++ developers?
A few, all right.
[INAUDIBLE] Make, maybe
in conjunction with CMake.
Any JavaScript developers?
Familiar with Webpack or Gulp?
These are all different
builds systems,
and there's many, many more.
So the headline for
today is that you
have a choice of build systems.
And the choice you
make can actually
have an important impact on
the success of your build.
You might be able to get faster
builds and tests, possibly
much faster.
Bazel is Google's
build and test system.
Open source, available for free.
And it's designed from
the ground up to be fast.
We can use GCP as
an uplevel for Bazel
to get even faster
build and test, reliably
and consistently.
All right, let's dig in a little
on this build and test thing.
Why do we build and test?
Well, build [? is ?]
a requirement.
Our software won't
work until we turn it
into something that can run.
Test is a choice.
But it's a choice that
we're all making, right?
Well, let's talk about that.
There is a wide body of
research talking about how
testing is really good.
Testing makes your code better,
which makes your users happy,
which makes your
organization happy,
which makes us successful
as individuals.
And when we add automation,
we can do testing at scale.
We can grow our code base,
grow our organization,
and keep our software running
successfully, correctly.
So look at the slide.
It's all green.
Whoops, meant to get the
laser here-- the green laser.
It's all green.
There's no red,
there's no pro/con.
We're all doing it, right?
We've totally
bought into testing,
and this is in our bones
at this point, right?
Or is it?
We did a study at Google across
hundreds of organizations.
And what we found is
that test practices
are falling far short of
what our ambitions are.
Very few organization
build every time
they make a code change.
And even fewer have
comprehensive test coverage,
by which we mean we have
tests that cover every code
path in our application.
It's really common for a team
to only run their complete test
suite once a day, maybe less.
And that complete test suite
is not all that complete.
So why aren't we testing?
Do we really like getting woken
up at 3:00 AM in the morning?
No, I don't think that's it.
We know the benefits, and we
have the best of intentions.
And then reality hits.
The more tests we
add, the more we
realize that it takes time and
resources to run these tests.
And it becomes a drag on
developer productivity.
It's very common to kick
off a build, and then
head out to lunch, right?
And then you come back, and--
OK, build's not done.
Let's go get some coffee.
All right, came back.
All right, still going.
I'm at 67%.
All right, I guess
it's beer o'clock.
All right, here we go.
Eventually, though, you
want to actually get back
to writing code.
So what do we do?
We take shortcuts.
We turn down our test coverage.
We run them less often.
And then that leads to bit rot.
Don't even write the test.
Why write them if you're
not going to run them?
And this is why we're
not testing at the level
that we feel we should be.
We end up in this
conundrum here.
As you step up your
test practices,
your code gets
better and better.
But your tests
take longer to run,
and you need more
and more hardware.
And that's a tough choice.
What's the sweet spot in here?
We can test more and more, and
take longer to get our code out
to production, or we can
test less, and get it out
there sooner.
It's we can ship it now,
or we can ship it right.
I don't know how to
make that choice,
and other people
struggle with it, too.
In our study, we found that the
number one concern among teams
with sophisticated test practice
is balancing test frequency
with the resources required
to run those tests.
So what if we could
flatten that curve?
Get to a place where we can
have more and more tests,
and run them more
and more frequently,
without incurring
increasing overhead
that spirals out of control.
Well, hello, Bazel.
Bazel is Google's build system.
It's been used by
nearly every one
of Google's thousands of
engineers-- tens of thousands
of engineers--
for over 10 years,
and it's available as
free, open source software.
At Google, we have an intense
commitment to testing.
We exercise and validate every
code path on every code change.
And most teams maintain a very
high level of code coverage.
As we grew, we ended up
running, as all of us
do, into this problem--
the conundrum of more
testing meant more time.
We didn't want to slow down
and ship software less often.
We didn't want to
ship more bugs.
So we created Bazel to allow
us to test all the things
without losing that velocity.
To do so, Bazel was designed
with two major optimizations
that allows us to run our build
and test more efficiently.
So the first is,
don't repeat yourself.
If you've already run something,
and it hasn't changed,
why run it again?
By reusing the prior
results, it means that we
can scale our build and test--
as our builds and tests
scale exponentially,
our time doesn't have
to scale that way,
because we're only going
to retest and re-exercise
the parts that have changed.
The second major optimization is
to build and work in parallel.
So build actions, and
especially tests, are generally
very parallelizable.
You might build one binary,
and run a whole bunch
of independent tests on it.
And so by having
this fanout ability,
we can run across
modern multicore systems
and get maximum efficiency.
What can you build with Bazel?
Well, just about everything.
Bazel provides an
extensibility mechanism
where you use a simple,
Python-like language
to write plugins.
We call them build rules
for various language.
This is just a partial
list of the set
of languages that have
been built by our community
to extend Bazel.
I've shown this
slide many times,
and I was at a conference
recently, showing it off.
And someone came
up to me and said,
all right, you've got a
lot of stuff in there,
but what about OCaml.
And I said, I don't know.
I don't know.
Went to my phone and
googled it, and found
out, oh, right, OCaml.
We have that.
So there's OCaml.
We actually play a
game at conferences
sometimes called
Stump the Bazel.
See if you can come
up with a language
that we don't have
bulit-in support for.
And if you do, it's
pretty easy to write.
You can use Bazel across
your entire organization
for every language that you're
working in today and tomorrow.
Let's take a look
at how Bazel works.
So first, consider a
traditional approach.
We're going to try and
build this code base.
This is a portion of the
TensorFlow code base.
It's actually much,
much more than that.
And our goal is to get to
an executable, something
that we can run.
So the traditional build process
works something like this.
First, we take all the
things, and then we
do this thing, and that
thing, and the other thing.
And then we cross our
fingers, and hopefully we
get something out that can run.
Now, there's two problems
with what I just described.
One is all the things.
Maybe we don't need
all those things
for this particular
thing that we're creating
and two is I said this, and
then that, and then the other.
This sounds very
serial, and I think
we know that modern software
is all about parallel.
So with Bazel, we took
a different approach.
The first thing we noticed
is that source code is not
a bunch of random stuff.
OK, mine sometimes is.
But eventually I figure
it out, and what I do
is I write source code that is
an interrelated set of highly
structured symbols.
So with Bazel, using a
declarative configuration
language, we define the units of
code and how they interoperate.
Bazel interprets that
to create actions,
and each action has fully
specified inputs and outputs.
These add up to a unique
signature for that action.
Each of these fully
specified action
is independent and can be
individually addressed.
We know everything that
goes into it and everything
that we expect to
come out of it.
We composite these into a graph,
where the output of one action
can become an input
into the next.
And these actions can be cached.
If the inputs to an
action don't change,
then we don't need to
regenerate the output.
All right, let's zoom out.
This is a graph of Bazel's build
graph, a directed acyclic graph
of all of the steps and the
flow to get from your inputs
to your output.
This represents
a very small one.
So let's say we're
going to make a change.
We'll make a change to
this file and that file.
Well, everything
upstream of that
is going to need to be rebuilt.
So we'll invalidate the cache
for all of these bits.
There's a fair
amount to do here,
but notice there's a whole
lot that we don't have to do.
And because of
Bazel's build graph,
we know for sure that
we don't have to do it,
and we're going to
get the right output.
The other thing we can
see is that this area
of the graph and this
area have no common edges.
And that means we can
execute them in parallel.
Now we're ready to build.
We rock the graph and
arrive at our output.
So putting it all together.
When I say, Bazel, let's
build and test this,
Bazel's going to
pull in the inputs,
generate that build graph,
then consult the cache
to see if there's
anything we can reuse,
prune out everything
that's already been built,
then distribute that work across
all the cores on my machine
for parallel execution
and rapid delivery.
All right, let's take a look.
Let's see, unlock
my laptop here.
So we're going to
build an application.
It's a modest Java application
for image recognition
using the TensorFlow library.
So it bundles TensorFlow's C++
native library to do the work.
And there we are.
All right, so we can see
it on the right here.
I'm running this using
Bazel as invocation runner.
It just makes it a little
bit more convenient.
And we say, hello, welcome
to the image labeler.
What should we take a look at?
All right, let's try
image number one.
It looks like that.
Who knows what that is?
Say it out loud.
AUDIENCE: Sunglasses.
DAVE STANKE: Sunglasses.
All right, do you think
TensorFlow agrees?
And yes.
Reasonable confidence.
Let's try another one.
All right.
What's that?
Can we guess?
We're actually at a little
bit of a disadvantage
here because of the ASCII art.
I'll show you the real thing.
What's that?
AUDIENCE: Strawberry.
DAVE STANKE: Oh yeah,
that's a strawberry.
And TensorFlow thinks--
strawberry, 99.98% confidence.
All right, it's working.
I'm going to make a change
to this application.
So I'm going to go
into the Java code
here, and do a vim, source,
main, Java, and then myself.
And then there's a
greeter class in here.
Oh, look what I've done.
All right, we got a
greeter class in here
that says hello to you, the
person running the program.
All right, so let's change
it to Hello Nexties.
We'll go ahead and commit that.
Why is my Escape
key not working?
There we go.
Oh my gosh.
Vim.
All right, did that work?
Yes, OK.
All right, and then we're
going to go ahead and rerun
our tests in Maven.
You can see that maybe is
going to kick up my test suite,
and go ahead and run through it.
Then we'll rerun in Bazel.
Bazel, test all.
So Bazel is going to
analyze all my files,
compile them, and
run in parallel.
Forgot to mention what
I'm running this thing on.
This is too GCE VMs,
16-core machines--
identical machines--
running Maven on the left,
and Bazel on the right.
Bazel ran in parallel
and, as you can see,
very rapidly found
that I have an error.
Oh, my error's in my test.
So we'll go ahead--
actually, I'm
going to wait for Maven
to continue, to finish.
Maven's running through
all of its tests,
taking a little longer because
it's not parallelizing.
Still doing all the work.
And it should be
just about done here.
There it is.
And they found the same failure.
All right, so the
failure's in my test class.
Let's go ahead and edit vim,
source, test, Java, blah,
blah, blah.
And I have a greeter test,
and this funny stuff again.
Go ahead and edit anyway.
All right, and what did we say?
We said Hello Nexties.
That's catching on, right?
We're calling ourselves that?
Nexties.
All right, and we'll save that.
And now we have it on this one.
So what do we do?
We say just continue, right?
All right, and then we're going
to rerun our build and test
action, Maven on the
left, Bazel on the right.
So maven's kicking
off, and run-- oh.
I've failed somehow.
But as we can see, Bazel
did it much faster.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DAVE STANKE: See,
this is a coding test.
Thank you.
Success.
And go ahead and capital that.
Rerun.
It's only going to rerun
that one test that changed.
And we passed in a very
short amount of time.
Whoops, what button was that?
All right, so to recap with
Bazel, we made a change.
Bazel's going to
look at its cache
and not bother rebuilding
anything it doesn't need to.
Then it's going to fan out and
use all the cores on my machine
to build in parallel.
Now, I was running this
demo on 16-core machines.
Do you use a 16-core
machine every day?
Maybe you do.
I don't.
I use this little
laptop with two cores.
And sure, you can give
all of your developers
16-core machines.
And most of the time, they're
going to be real happy.
Running and IDE doesn't take
a whole lot of horsepower.
And if we're doing
a modest build
process, still pretty good.
It's a little wasteful, but
everything is working fine.
But eventually, these
machines are going
to start to look underpowered.
This is because build
is intrinsically
a spiky workload, which means
our developer machines go
from being overpowered
to underpowered.
And yes, even with
Bazel, because Bazel
can exercise all of the
cores on one machine,
but it can't conjure up
new cores out of thin air.
Or can it?
Remember, each of
these Bazel actions
is an independent
unit of execution.
Which is how we can cache
so aggressively and shard
across all the
cores of a machine.
So how about we tap into
the cloud and get a bunch
more cores?
We can scale way beyond
a single machine.
And everyone in
the team can share
that pool of worker cores.
So we can bin pack
those spiky workloads.
When I need a build, I'm going
to grab a bunch of cores.
And when I'm done, you can
grab a bunch of course.
And we can scale the
total pool to whatever
we need for our team.
Also, we can move our
cache up into the cloud.
So if anyone on my team has
previously built something,
then everyone gets
to reuse that work.
This is great for getting
new team members onboarded.
A first build for
a new team member
isn't starting from scratch.
It's starting from
whatever the build
was that the experienced
person made yesterday,
or this morning.
Today, I am excited to
introduce Remote Build
Execution for Bazel.
It's a Google Cloud Platform
service, which has just
been launched to alpha.
It's inspired by the services
that we use internally
at Google, which are a big part
of supporting our engineering
culture and commitment to tests.
It's based on open
source APIs developed
by the Bazel community.
This is a fully managed
Google Cloud Service,
provides scalable worker
pools for massively parallel
build and test workloads,
and a shared cache
that every build client,
whether a developer or CI, can
leverage.
Let's see it in action.
So we're going to build
that same application
that we looked at earlier.
But this time, we're going to
go into the TensorFlow source
code.
TensorFlow is a huge project.
Massive C++ source code, tens
of thousands of files and tests.
Let's make a change.
So, vim.
If we go into the
core here live,
there's some string libraries.
And here's a file within there.
And we're going to modify
this global identifier.
Let's see.
So what should we have
our global identifier be?
Let's go with
Hello-- oh, all caps.
Didn't mean that.
Hello Nexties.
I feel like I heard
someone saying.
It's like, what people
are calling the attendees.
And go ahead and
quit out of that.
And then on the left
side, we'll go ahead
and rebuild with Bazel.
And of course, it's going to
run through all of its inputs,
and figure out what
work needs to be done,
and distribute that
across all 16 cores.
OK, there's 7,000
or so different bits
that it needs to run.
It's actually going to
find a few more as it runs.
On the left, we'll
run that same thing.
Test, colon all-- oops--
all.
This time, I'm going to use
a configuration that includes
remote build execution.
Do that same analysis, and start
running, and oh my gosh, look.
We are running on 600 cores.
So this work is
being distributed
to 600 individual
workers in the cloud.
This is, again, using that
open source protocol for remote
build distributions.
Based on gRPC and Protobuf.
And it uses docker containers to
provide an isolation mechanism.
The container is where
your work gets executed,
and that's part of the input
to the build that's happening.
And it's executed in our
fully managed service that
carries the same commitment
to performance, reliability,
and security that you've
come to expect from GCP.
So now, another benefit
of working in the cloud
is that we can send our
outputs to a shared place.
So I want to show you a cool
additional feature, which
is this UI for build results.
This is representing the
build I'm doing right now.
You can see a list
here of all of the work
that Bazel has
decided it needs to do
and is currently
running through.
And a successful rate,
and some of them that
haven't happened yet.
We've got our invocation log.
Here's a full list of
the invocation details.
This is what Bazel
is going to do.
And we can get artifacts, the
things that Bazel has built.
We can go ahead and download
our intermediate libraries
and things straight
out of the cloud.
This is available to
everyone on your team.
So if I'm having a
problem building,
I can go to my overview page.
I can take this
link, and copy that,
and send it to a colleague.
And they can understand
my build and the
needs that I have without
having to redownload and rebuild
everything themselves.
Or they can go ahead
and rebuild based
on knowledge of
exactly what Bazel
build I did from this input.
Let's go ahead and refresh
and see how we're doing on our
build.
Looks like we're getting
pretty close here.
Check back in.
All right, now we've come down
to a bit of a pinch point.
And you can see that
we're doing our linking.
That tends to be a bottleneck.
We're still distributing
across dozens or hundreds
of individual nodes--
a lot more than I
could process on one team.
All right, and we've started
running into the tests.
And oops, I have a test failure.
Using this UI, that's going
to pop right to the top.
Here's my failing target.
Click into my strings
test, and what do we find?
Oh, right, I was supposed to
write Hello Nexties in my test,
but instead it still
says TensorFlow 1.9.
Again, this is a great way to
collaborate with teammates.
Send this to someone who
understands this test suite,
and they can help
me understand it.
I'm not a C++ expert, but in
this case it's fortunately
pretty clear what I'm
supposed to do about this.
Pop back over.
Still running off a few
additional finalized bits.
Final testing, and there we go.
We see a summary of all
the things that passed,
and that one test that failed.
I'm going to go ahead
and make an edit there.
And let's see, it's under
lib, strings, numbers, test.
And this time, we'll get
the capitalization correct.
So it was-- here, you know what?
How about we copy and paste?
No fat fingering here.
And go ahead and
paste that in, save,
and I'm going to
rerun my test suite.
This time, the only change I
made was to that one test file.
We're going to recompile
the test, which
is running again on the remote.
Going to relink that
to single action,
so it's running in single
threaded mode effectively.
And rerun.
And what you'll see is it cached
all of those previous results,
and only reran the one
test that I needed to run.
Again, this works
across your whole team.
So if I'm the one who
made the original error,
and my colleague
made the change,
they're going to inherit
all of the test results
that I got in the past.
This is really great
for making people
on your team
effective, fast, happy.
So to sum up, we
used a shared cache
to de-duplicate across
your entire team.
The shared worker pool
means I can parallelize
to the scale of the cloud.
And cloud-hosted UI
improves our effectiveness
as a team, communication,
and joint debugging.
Now, Cloud Build.
This was announced this week.
Hopefully you've been
hearing about this.
It's a fully managed
CICD system on GCP,
and it has out-of-the-box
support for Bazel built in.
There's a supported
build step, which
makes running Bazel workloads
and cloud build really simple--
just a couple lines of code.
And it's got a
Bazel-optimized results
UI for collaborative
troubleshooting.
So you can have Cloud
Build driving your process
as part of a CI system,
getting that same shared
cache and same shared
giant cloud compute pool.
Using RBE for your CI builds
enables you to fully test
every single change.
From one commit to the next,
typically these are all small,
incremental changes.
And so then the same is
true of pull requests,
and even developer builds.
Using the shared cache
in the distributed pool
means that every change can be
tested, because everyone's only
going to reperform the amount
of work that it needs to do.
So the time it takes
to run your test suite
is proportional to the
amount of change made,
not to the total size
of the code base.
With Remote Build
Execution, we've
been partnering with several
teams, Google projects, and GCP
customers as part of an
early access program for RBE.
And these partners have
seen great improvements
in build speed and reliability.
Some of the workloads our
customers are running include
Scala web services,
C++ system libraries,
and IDEs written in Java,
where we're doing full headless
testing of those interactive
environments in the nodes
on RBE.
One of those customers is the
TensorFlow team themselves.
They built their very large
polyglot project on RBE.
And they've been piloting
Remote Built Execution with us,
and have achieved a 5x
improvement in their
build speed.
That's coupled to a 5x reduction
in the amount of machinery
necessary to do these workloads.
So 5x plus 5x--
I don't know if
that's a 10x or a 25x,
but it's a lot of x's, and we're
really excited about what we're
being able to achieve here.
They used to have a long
backlog of pull request testing.
They had this one
poor engineer who
had to very carefully
mete out the test
against this fragile
infrastructure.
By using these
services, they've been
able to run on demand every pull
request, a real linear flow,
and their contributors
are much happier.
So, summing it all up, Bazel
makes your build faster
by maximally reusing
prior results
and fanning out the
remaining work across all
of the cores on your machine.
With GCB, we take it
to the next level,
globally reusing prior
results and fanning out
to work across the
cores in the cloud.
If you're ready to get
started with Bazel,
there you can find installers
for Mac, Windows, and Linux
on the Bazel website, as
well as demos, tutorials,
and great documentation.
You'll also find references
to the community.
We've got a mailing
list at Bazel Discuss.
Very active.
Stack Overflow communities.
And we have a conference
coming up in New York.
This year is our second
annual Bazel conference,
BazelCon 2018, in October.
Find information for
that on conf.bazel.build.
To get started
with Bazel on GCP,
shoot us an email at
rbe-inquiries@google.com.
Again, that's
We have found from our own
testing "inquiries" is actually
kind of hard to spell.
So take a picture of
that, and type it exactly.
Maybe those new G Suite features
you saw will help autocorrect
it, I'm not sure.
But please, reach out to us.
We'd love to learn
about your builds,
challenges you're having,
and how we can help you
have faster, more
reliable builds.
We also have a couple of the
senior engineers from the team
here in the room today.
They and I will all be outside.
We'd would love to talk to you.
That's them.
Please come, and tell
us what you're up to,
and ask us questions.
[MUSIC PLAYING]